well the india now where public health
experts are sounding the alarm about a
new variant of the virus that causes
covert 19.
more than 50 cases of the so-called
delta plus variant have been detected in
india and it's also surfaced in the usa
and almost a dozen
other countries indian scientists say it
could be more transmissible
more infectious and resistant to
life-saving drugs given to some covert
19 patients
but they need more data to confirm that
our correspondent namisha jaiswal sent
us this report from india where the new
variant has fueled fears the country
could be headed for a third wave
as restrictions are eased once again
after another coronavirus wave
crowds are thronging to the freshly
opened markets in india
already it is hard to imagine that just
two months ago
the country was recording over 400 000
cases a day
but the indian government is warning
that all is not well yet
a mutation called delta plus has
recently been declared a variant of
concern
an unwelcome message for many at this
delhi market
we should live in the present instead of
worrying about the future
it's been so long we've wasted one and a
half years overthinking this
it is going to be mutated every time
it's going to enter
so these variants are going to be there
so it's not like that the delta place is
something different
from a normal covert viruses the delta
variant was first detected in
india last year and was instrumental in
causing the massive second wave of cases
here
it is now steadily gaining ground as a
dominant variant around the world
driving an upsurge in cases in a number
of countries
the new mutation of this variant the
delta plus
has even been detected outside of india
this time delhi has been quick to react
after facing criticism for failing to
anticipate the crushing impact
of the earlier delta variant the indian
health ministry has warned
states that this virus mutation is more
transmissible
and more likely to resist antibodies but
experts say
it is far too soon to tell dr shahid
jameel
a senior virologist explains why this
latest variant is causing concern
we are worried because this mutation was
first seen
in the beta variant of concern something
that was earlier called the south africa
the beta variant is able to evade
pre-existing immunity much
better than all other variants of
concern
but he also emphasizes that more data
will be needed
to confirm if this variant is more
infectious or lethal
newspapers calling it something that
will
cause the third wave are simply alarmist
there is no evidence of that at this
point
for now experts say vaccinations are the
best way to fight off variants
like the delta and delta plus and after
a sluggish couple months
the pace of india's vaccine drive is
showing signs of improvement
with the government urging people to get
inoculated as soon as possible
the people waiting in this line for a
jab appear to have got the message
for more let's talk to ravi gupta he's a
professor of clinical microbiology at
the university
of cambridge professor gupta thanks very
much for your time
we know that there is still not enough
data yet on delta plus but
what do we know about it so far
well we know that it has uh uh obviously
emerged it
uh it's potentially ceded infections in
nepal
uh i believe and i believe that it ceded
infections in portugal
uh and and some of which have landed in
the uk but
i think that uh uh in general uh this is
a mutation that we have seen before a
number of times
even in the context of the alpha variant
the one that's originated in the uk
um and those viruses did not really uh
have an advantage
uh over the b117 uh in to any degree
and so um i would caution against
getting
overly worried about the the delta plus
and i think the delta event is
uh reason enough to be uh really
considering how we tackle this virus
without having to worry about the extra
mutation at the moment so i think that
um that it's a bit of a distraction what
we have to be dealing with globally is
the fact that we have a virus
that is rapidly spreading that does
evade immunity to a
significant extent and is highly
transmissible and infectious so um
that's the thing that we should be
discussing
then how confident are health officials
that existing vaccines are going to be
effective against
this new variant but also delta and and
other variants that may be popping up
well the the vaccines that we have were
designed against the the original virus
and they
still despite variants confer
very high levels of protection against
severe disease and death in
the majority of people however there are
vulnerable people who have responded
less well to the vaccine
who have lower levels of antibodies and
who will get severe disease
and and some will die but in the main
these viral vaccines are still highly
protective
uh everyone should be vaccinated if
possible
but there are going to be people in the
fringes as i say who become susceptible
to the new variants because they are
slightly less somewhat less uh
controllable by vaccine-induced immunity
how concerned are you like we're seeing
numbers rise again in parts of europe
we're seeing these variants this is also
at a time when
things particularly in europe are
opening up we're seeing sporting games
we're seeing
travel sort of reopening uh
how worried should we be are we walking
blindly into a new wave do you think
well certainly in the uk we are
experiencing
significant rises in cases uh and
i'm not so sure about the data from
europe but i will imagine that europe
will be lagging slightly behind
of course we have higher vaccination
coverage than most of europe so the
delta is a much bigger
risk for countries that have low
vaccination rates
and so yes i would be very concerned
about uh
this virus moving through populations
that are unvaccinated because it is
extremely infectious the
um you know the attack rate is high
we've shown in
healthcare workers in india that the
virus is able to transmit between
uh healthcare workers who are vaccinated
and therefore
um in hospitals this is a particular
risk
i believe and of course in the uk with
all these sporting events starting up
and
uh opening up of the um the restrictions
uh there is going to be a further surge
and we are going to get
huge numbers of cases there's absolutely
no doubt of that they will in the large
part be mild
but some again given that you know the
large numbers you know we will get
um you know it will have a cost attached
to it but that's going to be balanced
against
economic uh considerations professor
gupta thank you very much
ravi gupta professor of clinical
microbiology at cambridge
thank you